[Music]
speaking of uh steve's hot sister
is she hot is this a joke too i can't
she's pretty smoking i feel like i'm
getting baffled left and right here i
thought you guys were my friends you
guys have not seen her so it's it's
settled i was like dude i'd be i'd be
like into incest too she's she's so hot
my wife is like yeah you could perv over
her oh you got the pass
dude he's joking but legit my sister's
[ __ ] hot
no no but also too so this is one of
those weird things have you ever been in
a situation too where you've seen like
like a gorgeous model like hot as [ __ ]
10 out of 10 and you're like man what if
she had a brother wouldn't that be
awkward that's how awkward it is for me
it doesn't sound awkward you literally
just said yeah my sister's [ __ ] hot
right but it's just weird it's just one
of those crazy things it's just weird i
think it's just kind of used to it's
been yeah oh yeah i'm sure you got
ragged it's cause he's got like morning
wood every time he thinks about it oh
yeah oh you wake up with morning when
your sister's your first thought of the
morning no
usually looking over where my [ __ ]
lame ass wife is
foot in your face
record scratch how did i get here
all right so uh
there's a [ __ ] beginning of a sitcom
you might be wondering how did i get
with this ugly ass piece of [ __ ]
hey honey i'm going to my sister's house
you just saw her last night
even i'm leaving my sister's house
that's how i got here
so um you might be wondering why i'm
[ __ ] my sister
how i [ __ ] my sister
it's like a sick a woman is paranoid
that she'll
date a sibling after discovering more
than 50 half siblings whoa whoa that's
in a movie or something i mean is this
like in utah
well the thing is she discovered that
she has more than 50 half siblings
because she has a sperm donor dad oh
oh my god was it vince vaughn yeah that
sounds like it but he's like 10 000 kids
because he was so broke he's just
jerking off into a cup only three months
or like six months anybody know how much
you paid for sperm donations dude i've
asked it's a couple hundred bucks i
think what was it i heard now they're
doing some genetic [ __ ] so maybe if i'm
an athlete maybe i'll get a little more
mmm
cancer in the family yeah they're
looking for that real aryan blood maybe
they made me pay
just to ball the porn magazine don't you
guys pay me and they're like abs no no
not your case first google says be a
sperm donor earn up to four thousand
dollars in six months
i'm in
it says up to four thousand dollars in
six months for one to two hours each
week in exchange for your commitment i
like how committed two hours how
viciously are you incentives and bonuses
over time yeah one or two hours each
week
that's two hours oh in a week yeah but
not in one session it's like you're not
like like enjoying the donation like
every day you're jacking it
yeah but yeah i guess every day you're
jacking off you could probably if you
jack off every night that's about an
hour a week do they pay you by ounce or
by hour it's got to be at least an hour
by grams actually yeah donors earn 140
for each acceptable sperm sample most
that's it it's a week 140. some donate
more often most donors earn 500 to 700
per month and men of color can empower
families of color by donating sperm whoa
do you think that enough i'm latin
let's go do you think the self-starter
like uh instagram people are like like
wake up grind drop in pints
another day let's go
liquid white gold i make money
swipe up by the way i'm kind of tired
right now i'll see y'all later
everyone's on that drop shipping grind
i'm on that drop coming grind come on
let's go
swipe up and run your course
what's the uh uh law
with like half like in incest and like
half stuff what do you mean like like i
know each state is different
like florida i think you can do like
your second cup you can [ __ ] your sister
right like the south is like second oh
the state brings it closer and closer
and closer i think depending where you
live the law i think some places it's a
state brings it closer i think per state
they just look the other way more yeah
like mississippi
i'm pretty sure the prince and princess
of south carolina are brother and sister
i didn't know that they're one of the
only remaining royalty in america is
that a thing yeah the prince and
princess of south carolina have you ever
seen the whitaker family
wait they have a
it's really called the prince and prince
princeton south carolina of south
carolina yeah it's real well you know
like the genetic stuff where uh is it
just a made-up title like no it's just
like line back to europe yeah their
their lineage goes you guys are [ __ ]
idiots sometimes
that couldn't make sense
that was fun i don't know you know
history [ __ ] i don't know i don't
[ __ ] know prince of prison in south
carolina though that's how i was like
that just sounds weird you're the only
one who sniffed it
everyone was like oh yeah a 23 year old
tick tocker from new jersey took to the
app to explain she has two moms and was
conceived using a sperm donor so she
decided to do a dna test to find out her
heritage
okay
she was surprised to learn that she's
not as italian as she first thought but
it wasn't until she received a message
from a random woman
that things started to get a little bit
funny she's probably throughout life
she's like man i gotta eat my culture's
food [ __ ] spaghetti like pizza
because you know like italians are like
that's the funny food is like so
hardcore oh yeah it is and then she
finds out and she's like wait
this ain't this ain't my and that
bothers her more than the fact that she
has 50 half siblings dude what's with
italians and constantly talking about
how they're italian it's like we [ __ ]
got it bro like well you know i'm
italian so like you know how it is it's
like we got it and they're [ __ ] so
naughty about the food you've got to
make pizza the right way we all know you
cracked the [ __ ] pasta why did you do
that this isn't real ravioli it's like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is it
it's [ __ ] ravioli okay
yeah dude i'm greek
[Laughter]
genius
you're not italian bro
yeah my last name wasn't farnachi i know
you're not italian because you don't
[ __ ] you never said one time i well i'm
italian you
know he's argentinian i'm more
argentinian yeah so do you think when
italians move to other places and then
they become that area they forget that
they're italian and now they're like no
way they announced their time when they
get there everywhere yeah like my family
moved into little italy uh in cleveland
would your family freak out if i was
about to make pasta and like crack the
noodles and then i put it in we're not
that italian okay
and then right after i took a [ __ ] on
the italian flag and started jerking off
the toilet
it's like if you're not like [ __ ]
doing this for noodles like you you
never get hungry at midnight you [ __ ]
idiots
good lord you're going back and cheese
instant mac isn't noodles though all
right that's my favorite i agree that
might show me out that was really cool
so uh so izzy gets a message from a
random woman asking if she's related to
a specific person or family because uh
she matched with her daughter and then
izzy says no
so then she asked if uh
she was a sperm baby because her
daughter was too and now she's freaking
out because she could be her sister
because she's a donor baby whoa so the
woman ends up
sending izzy an invite to a facebook
group of more than 50 people who were
all conceived using the same man's sperm
that is the vince vaughn did they figure
it out by like 23andme and stuff yeah
like a dna so let's not date if we're in
here let's not date
okay that's like the thing right oh
you're talking yeah
and it'll be fine a lot of chinese
people got ganges calm in them yeah
we are all getting this camera mailed it
that's why we don't do [ __ ] 23andme
we all find out the same have you guys
done it yet yeah we're gonna learn the
same [ __ ] can we all do it together and
just read it when do you think the first
person said come
on
like you know what it is it's well it's
called come as well as opposed to like
semen yeah well yeah is it an acronym i
don't know why did they come up with
that it's not like genghis khan's like
you just got giggus gum
that was his catchphrase actually
puts in her face that's right because it
comes from the mongolian era
oh my god language expert in here and
ask him important questions like that
we'll just [ __ ] pull him out of the
closet just when we want to say some
[ __ ] yeah yeah and get your ass over
here that is actually a good question
though where does that come
that's actually i could be your english
expert if you guys need one false in the
closet with no change but the past dance
is what change yeah
yes but the past tense is kane yeah true
when you did it yes it's also funny to
say i come down here
well i asked nikki all the time i did
you came
did
so she said now there's paranoia about
overpopulation because some of them are
afraid there are so many of us and we
may end up dating someone who happened
how [ __ ]
that many
small towns that's what i could say how
many people live yeah if they're all in
the same town that's kind of a
all
lot
same town but for them to all [ __ ]
have a facebook group they live in
alignment with each other to make sure
they can't [ __ ] each other isn't
hilarious i don't want to be i don't
want to be ignorant to oh they're all
hella ugly none of them are getting laid
anyways they're just freaking out over
nothing
so i don't want to be ignorant to what
it is to either be a sperm donor baby or
adopt or anything like that but um i'm
guessing there's that many ladies that
couldn't get laid no i was i'm guessing
that everybody eventually wants to like
kind of meet their maker in a sense oh i
said yeah and like like that journey
if you're gonna have 50 people
join a facebook group and then like
proactively find other people yeah or or
even to like the way they find them is
because other people are posting
themselves even if they don't have the
answer that they like ah i don't know
this or i i'm a sperm donor baby or
whatever whatever gives clues to why
there's got to be that uh i'm wondering
does everybody just do that does every
sperm donor baby eventually have to do
that or like uh even adoption i think a
lot of people do want to do i understand
that an adoption i guess somebody wants
to shoot a baby out of the [ __ ] though
that's why or what is it do you think
the sperm donor knows how many [ __ ]
babies he potentially i think he knows
how much money he got
yeah potential is what like 100 000
billion yeah right yeah
that was real
yeah yeah that's your second math joke
so i believed you 100 000 100 000
billion that was really just 100
oh 100 gazillion
what's that gazillion what's gazillion
is it real is that the godzilla era what
is that
let me see is kazillion real gee i think
it actually exists
call gazillion within i'm gonna call it
dropout what do i know gazillion what's
after trillium actually no like zillion
and jillian gazillion is a made-up word
what's after trillion
quadrillion
wow i want the cilia money
i want sextillion money baby that's what
bazel's chasing after the sex stealing
the bezos is ain't in the compensation
one but again back to the real
conversation of trillions though
sperm donor people
so if you [ __ ]
if you just donate a bunch of sperm for
the rest of your life you have no moral
obligation or
ideal connection yeah right yeah like
that's i assume so i i assume there's a
uh you don't even get [ __ ] why should
you take care of those kids exactly
that's true okay but so
let's say let's say you're a sperm donor
wait who can't get [ __ ] the donor
what if he's just doing it for money or
like no no but he's not [ __ ] the
girls he's just coming in the cup yup
you're right but what if his goal is not
to like raise a kid i'm just saying like
maybe maybe he's he is getting [ __ ] and
he's he's getting money and maybe he's
really really kind and he's worried
about all the ladies that have infertile
mans what a sweet person oh he's just
trying to get laid
i don't think that works [ __ ] if you go
on the first date and say yeah i'm
actually a regular sperm donor i don't
think that helps no it doesn't doesn't
or if you're like hey yeah i do charity
work i've got a facebook group that
everybody's looking for me somewhere
yeah i do a lot of charity work
but i mean there's got to be more than
one facebook group out there that has
like this type of thing and there's also
got to be people that end up confronting
those people or finding their sperm
donor father right yeah for sure which
is why they probably even made a movie
right like yeah how does how does [ __ ]
like that where i just think it was my
[ __ ] mind if you had like 50 plus
children out there that came out of your
sperm and you don't know anything about
them yeah do you when you buy sperm do
you choose does it have like a label
like usually when i buy it on tuesdays
right yeah
they're freshest yeah that's when the
eggs are fresh out there who know who
their kids are and they don't want to
know them and then anthony's in here
worried that all these sperm babies
aren't going to know their family
the [ __ ] cutest [ __ ] mental
mindset i've ever heard about
[Music]
huh
[Music]